tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
jean paul ii à saint domingue
je suis le pèlerin de l'amour et de la
paix iran les aéroports fermés à nouveau
pour trois jours
l'ayatollah appels au renversement du
gouvernement bakhtiar le président
valéry giscard d'estaing l'école de
police de cannes ecluse la police doit
être assurée de la confiance de
l'opinion un médecin en justice pour la
mort d'un enfant
la responsabilité médicale en question
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
c'est avant tout un pèlerinage deux fois
le pape jean paul ii a ainsi résumé le
but de son voyage en amérique latine
lors d'une courte allocution prononcée à
l'aéroport de rome fiumicino ce matin
jean paul ii a expliqué je me rends dans
le nouveau monde comme messager de
l'évangile pour des millions de frères
et de soeurs qui croient dans le christ
je veux tous les connaître les embrasser
leur dire que dieu les aime
que l'église les aime que le pape les
aime depuis son élection jean paul ii à
montrer souvent sa générosité dans des
gestes spontanés ce qui n'a pas toujours
été d'ailleurs apprécié de la curie
romaine ce gouvernement de l'église peu
habitué à ce genre d'attitude
jean paul ii a montré une fois de plus
sa décontraction vis-à-vis des horaires
en prenant une bonne demi heure de
retard par rapport au planning officiel
à l'aéroport de rome fiumicino avant de
prononcer quelques phrases pour
caractériser le but de son voyage
jean paul ii avait été accueilli par le
chef du gouvernement italien à l'immense
tube monsieur andreotti jean paul ii
était accompagné par le cardinal
secrétaire d'état jean vigneau qui
assure en l'absence du pape la gestion
des affaires ordinaires de l'église si
les voies du seigneur sont impénétrables
les routes du ciel réserve aussi parfois
quelques surprises
l'avion du pape n'a pu suivre en effet
le chemin initialement prévue au dessus
de l'espagne et du portugal en raison de
turbulences le commandant de bord a pris
la décision d' infléchir sa route vers
la france
le saint père a ainsi transmis par la
radio de bord
un message au président valéry giscard
d'estaing et au peuple français
je suis heureux d'exprimer mes souhaits
de bonheur formulées dans la prière
mon intérêt pour la culture française
mon estime de son souci du droit de
l'homme et ma confiance dans sa vitalité
spirituel l'avion du souverain pontife a
ensuite poursuivi sa route en direction
de la république dominicaine un petit
état qui prend la moitié de l'une des
premières îles des antilles l'autre
étant occupé par haïti le choix de la
république dominicaine n'est pas un
hasard c'est le pays le plus catholique
du monde avec un taux de plus de 95%
c'est aussi en république dominicaine
que les espagnols construisirent en
15/100 11
la première cathédrale du nouveau monde
celle de saint domingue
sur place les envoyés spéciaux de tf1
ont assisté à l'arrivée de jean paul ii
qui pour son premier voyage officiel a
reçu un accueil populaire d'une chaleur
exceptionnelle
jacques hébert je serai le pèlerin de la
fois dit jean paul ii aux journalistes
présents dans le dc10 d'alitalia
spécialement affrétés par le vatican et
c'est sous un soleil splendide et avec
25 degrés de température qu'à 13h30
locales il était 18h30 en france l'avion
pontifical a été riche sur l'aéroport de
saint-domingue
un vent faible a fait tomber vous venez
de voir le grand manteau rouge jean paul
2 mentaux que le pape ne remettra pas
sur ses épaules
préférant rester en soutane blanche un
premier signe de simplicité la
simplicité par laquelle il entend
marquer tout son voyage en amérique
centrale
arrivé au bas de l'échelle de coupée le
souverain pontife aura comme premier
geste d'embrasser le sol dominicain
geste symbolique qu'avait eu le pape
paul 6 lorsqu'il s'était rendu à
jérusalem le pape apparemment peu
marquée par dix heures d'avion et
visiblement très ému cette émotion qu'on
avait déjà ressenti lorsque le 16
octobre dernier
il apparaissait pour la première fois au
balcon central de la basilique saint
pierre
après les traditionnels coups de canon
marquant l'arrivée d'un chef d'état
étranger après les ihm dominicains et
pontificaux jean paul ii a prononcé ses
premières paroles en terre américaine
une terre ce saint domingue où plus de
95% de la population et donc baptisé sur
la terre la première terre atteinte par
christophe colomb il ya maintenant près
de cinq siècles dans un espagnol parfait
le souverain pontife déclarera ma visite
est une entreprise d'évangélisation et
c'est pour cela que j'ai souhaité arrivé
ici en suivant la route contre assez les
premiers évangélisateurs
premier salut au peuple dominicain
premières embrassades aussi vous allez
le voir avec des enfants
après son discours après ces premières
embrassades jean paul ii prendra place à
bord d'un étrange véhicules couverts
d'une toile blanche ce genre de véhicule
que l'on peut voir sur les terrains de
golf et qui conduira le souverain
pontife lentement toujours entouré par
de nombreux policiers dans le centre
ville distant de 30 kilos mais alors
qu'il est le souverain pontife prend
quelques minutes de repos avant de
célébrer une messe en plein air et en
plein centre de la capitale dominicaine
où sont déjà massés plusieurs centaines
de milliers de fidèles
demain matin départ pour le mexique où
jean paul ii inaugurera la troisième
conférence générale de l'épiscopat
latino américains une conférence qui
sera essentiellement marquée par les
difficiles rapports dans cette région
entre l'église et les pouvoirs
politiques
après mexico une messe célébrée à notre
dame de guadalupe
ce sera la rencontre avec cinq cent
mille indiens arawaks aka la rencontre à
guadalajara avec des dizaines de
milliers d'ouvriers et enfin le retour à
mexico où le pape rencontrera les
étudiants à neauphle le château dans la
banlieue parisienne un autre chef
religieux l'ayatollah khomeiny a été
longuement applaudi par une foule de
croyants et de partisans tout à la fois
qu'ils ont sans doute tentés par la
chaleur de leurs acclamations de
compenser l'annulation d'un projet cher
au coeur de l'ayatollah son retour en
iran et son triomphe qui était prévue
demain
mais vous le savez monsieur bâtir le
premier ministre iranien qui tente de
sauver en iran ce qui peut encore être
sauvés du chaos et de l'affrontement
avec l'armée monsieur bakhtiar a donné
l'ordre à l'armée d' investir l'aéroport
de téhéran où aucun mouvement d'avion ne
pourra avoir lieu dans les trois jours
le chef religieux chiite a donc été
obligé de reporter son départ et il a
dénoncé je cite la trahison du
gouvernement bakhtiar en appelant le
peuple à renverser ce pouvoir illégal
avec gérard saint paul l'analyse de la
situation nouvelle
ainsi créée l'ayatollah khomeiny n'a pas
perdu la partie mais il a manqué son
rendez vous et il a peut-être perdu
psychologiquement tout au moins le début
de la première manche dans les duels qui
l'opposent monsieur bastien lui l'homme
de dieu pour lequel le compromis
n'existe pas donne l'impression de
prêter son retour au marchandage ses
partisans attendaient que les pistes de
l'aéroport de téhéran s'ouvre comme par
miracle devant son avion et que les
chars ses cartes en forme de haie
d'honneur
or voici qu'aujourd'hui ils se
retrouvent à la merci d'une négociation
de bazas pourquoi parce qu'en dépit de
sa dignité imperturbable il se heurte à
des choses simples et techniques sur
lesquels joue bach ya un aéroport fermé
peut s'opposer à toutes les volontés
politiques
désormais ce sera donnant-donnant pour
khomeiny en apparence alternative reste
simple oui à la discussion avec bakhtiar
à condition qu'il démissionne comme
tehrani le président du conseil de
régence retour à téhéran de toute façon
et sans délai mais voilà ben attia
résiste et montre qu'il a des moyens à
sa disposition via leur genre saint paul
est ce que vous pensez que les aides
l'arménie peut sous-estimer la capacité
de manoeuvre de monsieur bakhtiar
peut-être en tout cas bakhtiar existe il
veut gagner du temps pour cimenter son
alliance avec l'armée qui reste larbitre
de la situation d'où le délai de trois
semaines comme conditions au retour de
l'ayatollah khomeini délai non précisé
ensuite aujourd'hui il joue sur la
lassitude pour désamorcer le phénomène
from any monsieur bastia et pour en
quelque sorte le normaliser le banaliser
à l'intérieur de la constitution mais il
ne pourra pas bouclé indéfiniment
l'aéroport de téhéran hervé ni qui a
attendu 16 ans son retour sort à
patienter quelques jours de plus en
essayant de ne pas se compromettre et en
préférant en apparence toujours les
risques du désordre à la loi de bastia à
téhéran robert bichat
déroulé devant le parlement un des
premiers ministres canadiens éprouvent
un tiers les partisans de khomeiny
pouvait un coup de mer vendée le vouloir
ignorer un gouvernement incompressibles
conséquent s'attendre à devoir verser
ses partisans emporté avec détermination
envers des phares un terrain le
président valéry giscard d'estaing a
passé plus de quatre heures aujourd'hui
en compagnie des dirigeants de la police
française lors de sa visite à l'école
nationale de police de cannes écluse en
seine et marne une visite qui tombe en
pleine actualité de grogne policière
puisqu'elle survient quelques jours
après la manifestation des policiers à
paris qui ont réclamé davantage de
moyens pour assurer leur sécurité
c'est à dire pour assurer la sécurité
des citoyens
le président valéry giscard d'estaing a
visité des exemples concrets de
d'entraînement de policiers est
également de succès récemment remporté
par la police notamment le dernier
laboratoire de drogue découvert en
france en 1977 à la ciotat puis le
président de la république a donné son
sentiment sur le rôle de la police
elle doit être at il dit un exemple
permanent de dévouement de maîtrise de
soi et de sens de l'intérêt public
françois bonnes mains
cette visite était prévue depuis
novembre dernier afin de rendre hommage
à l'inspecteur capella tués en juillet
1978 lors de la fusillade de l'ambassade
d'irak le président de la république a
découvert une plaque à sa mémoire en
présence de son père et de sa femme
mais ce que les policiers attendaient
avec intérêt c'était bien entendu le
discours du président premier thème
développé la sécurité vouloir la
sécurité de chacune et de chacun c'est
vouloir d'abord arracher les racines de
la violence
cela concerne la famille l'éducation la
vie sociale tout entière
c'est donc aussi une responsabilité dont
chacun de nous voir reconnaître qu'il
détient sa part 2e thèmes évoqués après
avoir rappelé les mesures prises
récemment le président a évoqué la place
de la police
des propos qui n'ont ni satisfait ni
rassurer les syndicats de police
présents à cannes ecluse la police n'est
pas isolé dans la nation j'attache une
importance essentielle à la
considération que la société porte à
ceux auxquels elle confie le soin
d'assurer sa sécurité
il ne peut pas s'agir d'une
considération à éclipse qui soit
fonction de la menace ou du danger
ressenti cette considération doit
reposer sur la constatation du fait que
dans une société organisée
ceux qui exercent la mission permanente
de garantir sa sécurité doivent être
considérées comme assumant qu une
fonction essentielle est assurée à tout
moment de la confiance de l'opinion un
léger contretemps a marqué le départ de
valéry giscard d'estaing son hélicoptère
n'ayant pu décoller il a pris place à
bord de l'appareil de secours de l'armée
de terre il faut s'attendre des
initiatives d'envergure plus vaste et
plus unitaire en lorraine et dans le
nord pas de calais c'est monsieur
krasucki secrétaire de la cgt qui a
lancé cet avertissement lors d'une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui les
luttes menées en lorraine ne seront plus
seulement défensive mais offensive a
poursuivi monsieur krasucki aujourd'hui
plus de 2000 élèves des établissements
secondaires du bassin de longwy ont pris
cet après-midi le relais des dix mille
enfants des écoles primaires qui avaient
manifesté hier pour exprimer leur espoir
de vivre d'étudier et de travailler au
pays
le premier ministre monsieur raymond
barre a reçu à l'hôtel matignon pendant
plus de deux heures une délégation
d'élus de la région nord pas de calais
avec à sa tête monsieur pierre mauroy et
à sa sortie de l'hôtel matignon monsieur
me roy a déclaré qu'il avait mis en
garde le gouvernement
celui ci risquant d' allumer dans le
nord pas de calais un au fur josiah
sommes heurtés à une position
catégorique du gouvernement qui
maintient son plan ce qui concerne la
suppression des emplois sur la
sidérurgie
or nous avons dit au premier ministre
que nous ne voulions pas que la région
du nord pas de calais se transforme sur
ce point en un immense bureau dette
sociale
donnez vous voulez fermer des hauts
fourneaux mais il ya un haut fourneau
qui est en train de s'allumer
c'est le haut fourneau sociale celle aux
fourneaux la colère là dans le
valenciennois on n'acceptera pas des
mesures visant la disparition des
emplois on les accepte pas la mission
d'information parlementaire chargée
d'étudier les problèmes de la sidérurgie
lorraine a fait un premier commentaire
cet après midi à lille le président de
cette mission monsieur rossinot député
udf a déclaré nous ne pouvons que nous
faire l'écho des inquiétudes et du
sentiment d'injustice des populations
que notre mission d'information
parlementaire a rencontré claret nous ne
pouvons que nous faire l'écho des
inquiétudes et du sentiment d'injustice
des populations que notre mission
d'information parlementaire a rencontré
ces dernières semaines il va y avoir
huit cent soixante treize nouveaux
licenciements dans le groupe renault
véhicules industriels berrier ça vienne
c'est ce qu'affirme la cgt la
confédération générale du travail croit
savoir qu'il s'agirait d'un licenciement
collectif pour des raisons structurelles
officiellement chez renault véhicules
industriels
le point sera fait sur cette affaire le
30 janvier prochain devant le comité
central d'entreprise mais il est sûr que
des licenciements auront bien lieu dans
une proportion qui n'est pas connu la
direction de renault s'efforcera de
réduire les conséquences sociales
toujours dramatique des licenciements
collectifs par des retraites anticipées
et des départs volontaires
après les licenciements annoncés hier
chez chrysler dont nous avons fait le
point dans le journal de roger gicquel à
20h ce soir le bilan de l'état de santé
de l'industrie du poids lourd en france
jean-louis burqa si le malaise dans
l'industrie automobile apparaît comme
une simple grippe
en revanche l'industrie du poids lourd
en français plus sérieusement atteintes
la fusion de berliet saviem l'été
dernier filiale de renault depuis 74 ans
n'a pas pour l'instant améliorer la
situation
en un an la production du groupe est
passée de 32 mille à vingt-huit mille
unités une baisse de près de 4000
véhicules qui reflète d'ailleurs la
situation du marché français
- 19 % par rapport à décembre 77 et -35
% par rapport à 76 la production de
poids lourds en france en 78 est égale à
celle d'il ya dix ans nous sommes
retombés au chiffre de 68 environ 48
mille camions les raisons sont
relativement simples le camion n'est pas
comme la voiture un bien de consommation
mais en bien d'équipement une entreprise
achète un poids lourd si elle pense que
grâce à cet achat elle va gagner de
l'argent
la crise a donc frappé de plein fouet le
marché du camion le trafic des
marchandises n'a pas cessé d'augmenter
mais pour réduire les coûts pour faire
face rose du pétrole les transporteurs
ont réagi en se regroupant et en
utilisant mieux leur flotte de poids
lourd aujourd'hui il n'est pas rare de
voir un camion tournait comme un avion
24 heures sur 24
et au lieu de perdre du temps à décharge
et on laisse par exemple sur place la
remorque on repart avec une autre déjà
plein et on récupère la première au
prochain voyage
les petits routier qui travaillent au
jour le jour ont donc pratiquement
disparu malgré ces difficultés il ne
semble pas cependant que les
constructeurs font c'est deux poids
lourds et en particulier renault ait
l'intention de baisser les bras
ce serait laisser la place aux allemands
au suédois et aux italiens
déjà bien implanté sur le marché
français est abandonnée une branche
d'activité qui concerne de près ou de
loin plus de cent mille personnes
un médecin anesthésiste de cannes
condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis pour une erreur de transfusion un
autre médecin anesthésiste à marseille
condamné à une amende d'un million et
demi de francs pour une autre erreur sur
un malade
ces deux jugements de la semaine
dernière illustre parfaitement le
problème de plus en plus aigu de la
responsabilité médicale
il fut une époque encore récente où le
médecin lorsqu'ils se tromper était fort
peu souvent sanctionnés par la justice
parce que les victimes ou les proches
des victimes considéré ces erreurs comme
l'émanation de la fatalité
mais depuis une dizaine d'années les
dommages et intérêts les procès se
multiplient
le phénomène est partie des états unis
résultat les polices d'assurance en
responsabilité civile des médecins sont
devenus exorbitantes en france nous n'en
sommes pas encore là mais voici tout de
même un nouveau procès retentissant
demain devant le tribunal correctionnel
d'annecy
un pédiatre de 50 ans est accusé
d'homicide involontaire par négligence
ayant diagnostiqué une méningite sur une
petite fille
ne l'a pas fait hospitaliser à temps
selon l'accusation la petite fille est
morte
le dossier de cette affaire jean pierre
berthet
au palais de justice donne si le procès
d'une bavure médicale un procès qui est
doublement significatif d'abord à propos
d'un certain malaise dans les relations
entre patient et médecin
ensuite en montrant ce qu'il faut
parfois d'obstination pour qu'aboutisse
au tribunal un dossier particulièrement
difficile sans préjuger du fond de la
faire il faut au moins reconnaître aux
époux croisille la vertu de la
persévérance cette avocate et son mari
ingénieur se sont battus pendant quatre
années à coup d'expertisé de procédures
diverses pour que toute la lumière soit
faite sur les causes du décès de leur
petit emmanuel la fillette a presque un
an quand la méningite se déclare
hospitalisés seulement le 4e jour c'est
à dire trop tard emmanuel sombre dans le
coma
son décès intervient après 14 mois de
survie artificielle
il ne s'agit pas d'une erreur le médecin
a évoqué l'hypothèse de méningite
malheureusement il avait raison et en
fait le seul reproche qu'on peut lui
faire ce n'avoir jamais utilisé aucun
moyen pour valider son hypothèse et ça
c'est une obligation qui est faite aux
médecins
l'inculpé le docteur base ils préfèrent
réserver ses explications juge mais le
conseil de l'ordre des médecins défend
publiquement son dossier est bien ce qui
nous dérange le plus c'est le battage
qui a été fait autour de cette affaire
c'est les moyens mis en oeuvre
l'intervention de mass médias qui sont
qui est tout à fait inhabituelle en
pareille matière et
la façon dont on a traîné ce médecin
dans la boue dont on a au fond sali son
honneur et sa dignité et notre mission
qu'on a nous conseil de l'ordre et
défendre cet honneur à sa dignité
et c'est pourquoi nous avons souhaité
intervenir il ya maintenant quatre ans
que vous avez perdu votre petit emmanuel
on va se demander pourquoi tant
d'acharnement
quatre ans après non mais je crois que
ce n'est jamais le monde au départ quand
nous avons voulu en parler on nous a dit
que nous étions disons incompétent pour
en parler parce qu'on était dans un
contexte passionnel aujourd'hui on le
dit quatre ans après pourquoi en parler
c'est de l'acharnement
alors à quel moment il faut en parler en
fait nous sommes coupables d'avoir osé
poser des questions d'avoir osé demander
des comptes
eh bien ça on ne reconnaît pas le droit
de le faire à votre avis quelles
conséquences sur l'exercice de la
profession de médecin peut avoir ce
procès je pense que ces conséquences
peuvent être grande
parce que l amèneront les médecins à
chercher d'abord à se couvrir et
ensuite à soigner le malade et c'est
absolument contraire au principe même de
l'exercice médical
en définitive tout peut se trouver remis
en cause si de tels procès devait se
multiplier qu'est devenu votre vie à
tous les deux depuis ce drame
oh il ya eu une grosse difficulté tant
que manuel a vécu si le terme si c'est
encore le terme qu'on peut employer
bon tout a été orientée sur emmanuel
kant emmanuel et est morte
nous avons voulu tourner la page et il
nous a fallu quelques temps et puis
ensuite nous avons eu des enfants nous
avons deux enfants maintenant bon ou non
une vie normale mais je crois que c'est
20 de dire parce qu'on nous l'a dit il
faut oublier maintenant emmanuel est
morte oublié on ne peut pas oublier ça
il faut que ça serve à quelque chose
demain début donc de ce procès avec jean
claude narcy maintenant la suite de
l'actualité bien je ne sais pas si vous
l'avez reçu jean claude bourret mais
certains d'entre vous ont déjà reçu le
formulaire de déclaration de revenus
pour 1978 pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
la voix si ya pas beaucoup de
modifications panne importante depuis
l'an dernier
pas de calcul à faire il suffit
d'indiquer le montant de ses revenus et
ceux de l'épousé éventuellement qui lui
a même un carbone pour vous aider pour
garder le double comme prévu la sncf a
annoncé qu'elle est autorisée à
augmenter les tarifs voyageurs de base
deux sets et demi pour cent le 1er
février prochain
cette mesure ne concerne pas les
voyageurs de la banlieue parisienne le
tarif de base sera portée à 33 centimes
21 par kilomètre en première classe et à
22 centimes 14 en deuxième place selon
un sondage sofres pour le nouveau
mensuel mieux vivre 64% des français et
67% des femmes estiment que la politique
de libération des prix entreprises par
le gouvernement en juin 78 et
responsables actuellement de la vie
chère qu'un société française à
l'honneur le ministre du commerce
extérieur monsieur jean françois deniau
leur a remis les oscars d'exportation
60,18 ce concours récompense les
industries de toutes tailles qui ont
obtenu les meilleurs résultats à
l'exportation la plus petite la société
sort mais l'installa deux ans on
travaille pour l'industrie horlogère à
l'emploi 110 personnes et puis la plus
importante près de cent mille salariés
et le groupe pechiney ugine kuhlmann une
de ses originalités consiste à mettre
son réseau international à la
disposition des pme
en seize c'est une initiative qui a
beaucoup intéressé le jury des oscars
patronnée par le centre français du
commerce extérieur dans le domaine de
l'exportation une bonne nouvelle la
france livrera 52 rames de métro à
l'egypte pour une valeur de 410 millions
de francs
ces rames représenteront la première
phase du métro du caire
et puis ce soir dans notre magazine
l'enjeu à 21h30 les nouveaux
exportateurs c'est terrifiant coréens et
les exportateurs de demain ses
innombrables chinois alain bel air au
coeur de la chine archaïque
jean françois delassus sedan l'accord
est capitaliste sont allés voir m un
géant de l'économie l'asie sur des
images exceptionnelles de jacky car
ghayoor également dans l'enjeu présenté
par françois de closets eurodif la
nouvelle cathédrale de l'atome
et puis le diamant un placement solide
avec emmanuel de l'attak gaston defferre
a été réélu président du conseil
régional provence alpes côte d'azur
c'est la sixième fois consécutive pour
le député maire de marseille en grande
bretagne la situation sociale ne
s'arrange pas du tout une nouvelle fois
les chemins de fer sont totalement
paralysée aujourd'hui par une grève
était totalement en tous les cas
beaucoup d'écoles et du sinn était fermé
mais monsieur callaghan refuse toujours
de proclamer l'état d'urgence
edgar faure a été reçu cet après midi
sous la coupole il succède à monsieur
endroit françois andré françois poncet
père de l'actuel ministre des affaires
étrangères il y avait beaucoup de
personnalités et des amis à la réception
du nouvel immortel
en particulier plusieurs membres du
gouvernement et le président senghor
selon la tradition monsieur dit harper a
fait l'éloge de son prédécesseur et
c'est le duc de castres qui lui a
répondu atterrissage forcé en algérie
pour un avion de ligne intérieure bilan
14 morts et dix blessés cela s'est passé
dans la région de béchar dans le sud
ouest algérien
on ne connaît pas les raisons incendie
du cs pailleron réduction des
condamnation en appel en effet
l'architecte michel quête un an de
prison avec sursis au lieu de 15 mois le
constructeur herbert lefebvre dix mois
avec sursis contre 18 mois et les
familles des victimes protestent
aujourd'hui ce soir contre ses
réductions de peine
paris va vivre à l'heure des collections
de haute couture en avant première voici
comment aller couturier parisien voit la
femme printemps étaient 79 féminisation
et séduction
sont les deux mots d'ordre des
couturiers pour le printemps été
prochain comme le montre ce croquis de
polisot las les épaules sont élargies
les tailles beaucoup plus fine
les juges ont un peu raccourci sous le
genou avec des fentes plus large
on est loin du folklore flou du
printemps dernier avec ce blazer d'
emmanuel ungaro aux épaules gonflante
sur une jupe drapée en crêpe de chine
pour pierre cardin une lignes
géométriques romantique soulignée par de
larges épaules une taille serrée et des
pantalons étroits et cool la robe poupée
de porcelaine de louis féraud elle est
en dentelle une ceinture de satin avec
un gros noeud aux anges
andré courrèges une ligne net 5 avec
cette chemise blouson en coton blanc sur
un pantalon de coton également mais rayé
des matières naturelles pour une allure
plus jeunes une silhouette longiligne et
sabre pour philippe bonnet avec des
manches gigot resserré sur le cloud une
taille corselet et puis une jupe droite
mais souple bonjour à tous et une ligne
tulipes confortable en vedette des
vestes trois quarts bien ceinture elle
paco rabanne très sophistiquée avec cet
ensemble combinaison pantalon en jersey
sauf le haut le haut de la combinaison
qui est en métal et une matière que le
couturier affectionne particulièrement
et puis enfin chez chanel une robe du
soir de longs gants noirs une voilette
le bas des jupes acquis de mousseline
bref comme un parfum des années 30
oui pour gagner le tiercé aujourd'hui si
vous avez joué bien il fallait mettre le
vin le 14 et le 8
ils rapportent dans l'ordre pour 5
francs 1340 france vous le voyez sur
votre écran avec les images de l'arrivée
et dans un ordre différent 268 francs
alors le vin le 14 et le 8
eh bien il fait toujours froid sur une
bonne partie de la france et mis à part
les privilégiés qui habitent entre la
côte basque et la côte d'azur par
ailleurs le thermomètre a flirté avec le
zéro depuis hier en effet les
températures ont baissé sur la france
elles sont même devenus inférieurs à
zéro dans le nord le nord-est et le
lyonnais demain vendredi des nuages avec
chutes de neige et verglas de la vendée
au bassin parisien et la frontière belge
le soir cette brusque aggravation météo
atteindra les landes le massif central
les ardennes et les vosges
le froid persistera sur une bonne partie
de la france seule la côte d'azur la
côte basque et les régions pyrénéennes
située au dessous de 400 mètres auront
des températures supérieures à 0 le
verglas est au rendez vous de la
dernière nuit de course du 47e rallye de
monte carlo
les pilotes s'affronte contre la montre
dans le col du turini un col que les
voitures vont emprunter à trois reprises
au cours de cette nuit qui commence
sauf accident toujours possible dans ce
genre de compétition le suédois
waldegard deux sur ford escort est bien
placé pour l'emporter puisqu'ils
comptent quatre minutes 7 secondes
d'avancé sur le finlandais allen c'est
d'ailleurs dans la fiat abarth piloté
par allen qui va tout faire pour
remonter son retard que l'équipe de tf1
dirigé par bernard giroux s'est installé
au moment de la reconnaissance cet après
midi voici donc le col du turini deux
jours comme si vous étiez au volant de
cette voiture de compétition c'est fiat
abarth
mais en ce moment les pilotes montent à
la lueur de leurs phares et plus de
50000 spectateurs enthousiastes les
applaudissent aux endroits stratégiques
beaucoup
on
m
la voilà exceptionnellement les
gendarmes n'avaient pas mis leur radar
fin de ce quarante septième rallye de
monte-carlo demain matin à 8 heures à
23h30 tout à l'heure le dernier journal
avec jacques fuchs merci pour votre
fidélité et bonsoir